друзі Що відбувається значить Зараз Коли
побачили що Серед присутніх значить є Ну
в тому числі я ті хто прийшов на
засідання погоджувальної Ради То тепер
погоджувальна рада начебто починається
пізніше о 10тій а о дев'ятій якась
закрита зустріч на яку пускають Як ви
бачите бачите оце голови фракцій
груп комітетів ще когось але от
народного депутата Гончаренка Ні ну
правильно нащо я на своєму робочому
місці Прийшов по закону мені навіть не
дають можливості працювати Ну от така
друзі історія Отака в нас демократія в
Верховній Раді України а це телеканал
Рада який знімав все Бачите народним
депутатам не можна а журналістам
телеканалу рада можна